Deutschland in der tiefsten Krise dieser
Energiekrise die Stimmung im Land
aufgeladen und der Bundespräsident
Frank-Walter Steinmeier mit einer
redezulage der Nation dieser Rede
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
jeder Mensch in unserem Land der am 24
Februar aufwachte
und die Bilder sah von
raketeneinschlägen in Kiew von
Panzerkolonnen auf ukrainischen Straßen
von der russischen Invasion auf
breitester Front
jeder der mit diesen Bildern erwachte
der wusste an diesem Morgen
war die Welt eine andere geworden
für niemanden ist der Schrecken dieses
morgens so entsetzlich wie für die
Menschen in der Ukraine selbst mit
einigen von ihnen saß ich am Dienstag in
karlovka
einer kleinen Stadt nahe der
weißrussischen Grenze saß mit Ihnen
zusammen in einem Luftschutzkeller
und diese Menschen erzählten mir ihre
Geschichten sie erzählten mir wie dieser
24 Februar
wie der Schrecken des Krieges in ihr
ganz normales Leben brach der ungeheure
Lärm der Einschläge der Rauch
Feuer
ihre pure Angst
und diese Frauen und Männer zitterten
als sie mir davon berichteten
eine ältere Frau erzählte
wie sie mit ihrem Enkel die vier endlose
Kette von russischen Panzern Lastern und
Kriegsgerät vorbei Rollen sah
und der Enkel sie ansah und fragte
Oma müssen wir jetzt sterben
die Großmutter konnte ihm die Frage
nicht beantworten und
das treibt ihr noch heute die Tränen in
die Augen
meine Damen und Herren jede und jeder
von ihnen
erinnert sich an diesen 24 Februar auch
ich als Sirenengeheul
der dunkle Rauch über Kiew die
schrecklichen Bilder dieses morgens
sie gingen und gehen mir unter die Haut
und sie markierten das endgültige
bittere scheitern
jahrelanger politischer Bemühungen auch
meine
genau diesen schrecklichen Moment zu
verhindern
der 24 Februar war ein Epochenbruch er
hat doch uns in Deutschland eine andere
Zeit in eine überwunden geglaubte
Unsicherheit gestört seine Zeit
gezeichnet Krieg Gewalt und Flucht
von Sorge vor der Ausbreitung des
Krieges zum Flächenbrand in Europa
eine Zeit schwerer wirtschaftlicher
Verwerfungen Energiekrise
der unser Erfolgsmodell der weltweit
vernetzten Volkswirtschaft
unter Druck geraten ist eine Zeit in der
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt das
Vertrauen in Demokratie mehr noch
das Vertrauen in uns selbst Schaden
genommen hat
Politik kann keine Wunder vollbringen
niemand auch kein Bundespräsident kann
in dieser zutiefst unsicheren Zeit alle
Sorgen nehmen im Gegenteil
ich glaube dass viele der Sorgen
berechtigt sind wie erfahren die tiefste
Krise die unser wiedervereintes
Deutschland erlebt
aber ich bin überzeugt wenn wir uns
diesen Moment diesen
Epochenbruch bewusst machen wenn wir uns
einen Begriff machen von dem Zeitalter
das zu Ende gegangen ist und dem neuen
Zeitalter des begonnen hat
dann und nur dann schärfen wir unseren
Blick für das
was jetzt von uns verlangt ist und ich
bin sicher dann müssen wir dieser neuen
Zeit nicht angstvoll oder gar wehrlos
entgegen sind meine Damen und Herren die
Jahre vor dem 24 Februar waren für
Deutschland eine Epoche im Rückenwind es
waren Jahre geprägt geprägt vom
Glücksmoment der deutschen Einheit
vom friedlichen Abzug der sowjetischen
Truppen vom Ende der
Blockkonfrontation und dem
Zusammenwachsen Europas es waren Jahre
der Friedensdividende von der wir
Deutsche in der Mitte des vereinten
Europas reichlich profitiert haben
und vielleicht auch das unser eigenes
deutsches Glück prägte unseren Blick auf
die Welt wir setzten darauf dass wir
von Freunden umgeben
der Krieg in Europa jedenfalls
unvorstellbar geworden sein Freiheit und
Demokratie Schienen überall auf dem
Vormarsch
Handel und Wohlstand in alle Richtungen
möglich
trotz aller Krisen jener Zeit und obwohl
natürlich nicht alles gelungen ist was
wir uns erhofft haben
diese Jahre waren gute Jahre
Deutschland ein Land mit dieser dunklen
Geschichte war
hineingewachsen in die Gemeinschaft der
Staaten respektiert sogar beliebt bei
den Partnern mit wachsenden
Gestaltungsspielräumen
auch wachsende Verantwortung in der Welt
und Deutschland ein Land so klein im
Weltmaßstab und praktisch ohne eigene
Ressourcen und Bodenschätze war eine
starke moderne global vernetzte
Volkswirtschaft geworden dank guter
Bildung und Ausbildung der Bereitschaft
zu Reformen und Handelsbetrieb der ganze
Welt deshalb sage ich diese Jahre mit
Rückenwind
sie waren gute Jahre nichts ist es eine
Entscheidung gefallen wir haben
gearbeitet für Frieden und Wohlstand wir
haben auf internationale
Kooperation gesetzt und nach Regeln
gespielt
und dann kam der 24 februar am 24
Februar hat Putin nicht nur Regeln
gebrochen und das Spiel beendet nein
meine Damen und Herren
er hat das ganze Schachbrett umgebracht
Russlands brutale Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine hat die europäische
sicherheitsordnung in Schutt und Asche
gelegt in seiner
imperialen Besessenheit hat der
russische Präsident
das Völkerrecht gebrochen
Grenzen in Frage gestellt
Landraub begangen der russische Angriff
ist ein Angriff auf alle Lehren die die
Welt aus zwei Weltkriegen im vergangenen
Jahrhundert gezogen hatte
heute sind diese gemeinsamen
friedenswarenden Lehren verblasst an die
Stelle des Austausches der Suche nach
dem verbindenden
tritt weltweit mehr und mehr des Ringen
um Dominanz
Chinas wirtschaftlicher und politischer
Machtanspruch ist darin ein zentraler
Faktor und dieses Ringen
wird die Zukunft der internationalen
Beziehungen auf lange Sicht prägen die
traurige die traurige Wahrheit ist
leider die Welt ist auf dem Weg in eine
Phase der Konfrontation obwohl sie doch
dringenden je dringender denn je auf
Kooperation angewiesen wäre Klimawandel
Artensterben Pandemien Hunger Migration
nichts davon lässt sich lösen ohne die
Bereitschaft und den Willen zu
internationaler Zusammenarbeit und
deshalb darf das Bemühen darum trotz
Krise und Krieg darf das Bemühen darum
nicht aufgegeben werden
meine Damen und Herren was bedeutet das
für uns in Deutschland meine Antwort ist
es kommen härtere Jahre
[Musik]
raue Jahre auf uns zu die
Friedensdividende ist aufgezehrt und es
beginnt für Deutschland eine Epoche im
Gegend
um in dieser Zeit zu bestehen können wir
auf die Kraft und Stärke bauen die wir
uns in den vergangenen Jahren erarbeitet
haben und helfen werden uns Erfahrungen
die wir bei der Überwindung anderer
schwerer Krisen gemacht haben vergessen
wir
bei allen Sorgen vergessen wir gerade
jetzt nicht wir sind wirtschaftlich
stark stärker als viele andere wir haben
gute Forschung starke Unternehmen ein
leistungsfähigen Staat und wir haben
eine große starke Mitte in unserer
Gesellschaft aber
[Musik]
zu den Stärken die uns bislang geholfen
haben
muss etwas hinzukommen
wir müssen
konfliktfähig werden nach innen wir nach
außen wir brauchen den Willen zur
Selbstbehauptung
und wir brauchen auch die Kraft zur
Selbstbeschränkung wir brauchen keine
kriegsmentalität
wir brauchen
Widerstandsgeist und Widerstandskraft
dazu gehört zuallererst eine starke und
gut ausgestattete Bundeswehr diese
Erwartung haben unsere Bürger
und die haben auch unsere Partner und
unsere Nachbarn wir sind das starke Land
in der Mitte Europas wir sind in der
Pflicht
unseren Beitrag zur bündnisverteidigung
zu leisten heute viel mehr als in einer
Zeit in der andere vor allem die USA die
schützende Hand über uns gehalten haben
wir konnten uns lange auf andere
verlassen und können das auch weiterhin
aber jetzt müssen sich andere auch auf
uns verlassen können
ich versichere unseren Partnern
Deutschland nimmt seine Verantwortung an
in der NATO und in Europa das zeigen die
sicherheitspolitischen Entscheidungen
der Bundesregierung seit der Zeitenwende
vom 24 Februar das zeigt vor allem aber
auch die breite öffentliche Zustimmung
mit der diese Entscheidungen getragen
werden
und das ist mir besonders wichtig
das zeigt vielleicht auch die wachsende
Aufmerksamkeit und der wachsende Respekt
für die Bundeswehr in der Breite unserer
Gesellschaft endlich sage ich das ist
höchste Zeit diese Gesellschaft braucht
eine starke Bundeswehr aber die
Bundeswehr braucht auch eine
Gesellschaft die ihr den Rücken stärkt
dafür werde ich als Bundespräsident
weiter einstehen
Konfliktfähigkeit und Widerstandskraft
erfordern noch mehr als das
in dem Maße in dem die Erwartungen an
uns wachsen
wird auch die Kritik an uns zunehmen
damit müssen wir
erwachsen umgehen nicht jede Kritik von
außen umgehend als Munition in der
innenpolitischen Auseinandersetzung
missbrauchen das ein Land wie unsere
sind der Kritik steht daran werden wir
uns gewöhnen müssen schauen wir auf die
USA die haben viel Übung darin die USA
sind globale Führungsmacht sie werden
kritisiert für das was sie tun und das
was sie nicht tun sie können nicht auf
andere zeigen oder höhere Instanzen
anrufen sie müssen wissen was sie tun
und warum und Deutschland
[Musik]
nein Deutschland ist keine globale
Führungsmacht aber wir sind einer der
großen in Europa von uns wird Führung
erwartet Führung im Interesse Europas
entscheidend ist nicht der Applaus des
Publikums entscheidend ist die Stärkung
Europas je unsicherer die Welt um uns
herum
desto sicherer müssen wir uns über
diesen gemeinsamen Weg sein meine Damen
und
zu einem offenen Blick in die neue Zeit
gehören
auch schwierige Fragen an uns selbst
die Welt seit dem Epochenbruch ist eine
andere und das bedeutet dass wir
von alten Denkmustern und Hoffnungen
Abschied nehmen müssen
das gilt ganz besonders für unseren
Blick auf Russland ich weiß dass viele
Menschen in unserem Land Russland und
seinen Menschen sich verbunden fühlen
russische Musik und Literatur lieben in
Ostdeutschland kommen ganz
unterschiedliche höchst Kontroverse
Erinnerungen an 40 Jahre Geschichte
hinzu die bis heute nachwirken im Osten
und im Westen sind wir dankbar für das
Wunder der Wiedervereinigung vergessen
nicht dass wir Michael Gorbatschow
verdanken dass sie friedlich blieb dass
die sowjetischen Truppen ohne einen
Schuss abzugeben nach Hause
zurückgekehrt sind
das hat viel Hoffnung auf eine
friedliche Zukunft gemacht
und diese Hoffnung hatte auch ich und
sie war Antrieb für meine Arbeit in
vielen Jahren
aber wenn wir auf das Russland von heute
schauen
[Musik]
dann ist eben kein Platz für alte Träume
unsere Länder stehen heute gegeneinander
Putin führt eine Invasionsarmee und die
Ukrainer verteidigen ihr Land dass sie
seit ihrer Unabhängigkeit seit 30 Jahren
aufbauen Russlands Angriffskrieg hat
Gorbatschows Traum vom gemeinsamen Haus
Europa zertrümmert es ist ein Angriff
auf das Recht auf die Prinzipien von
Gewaltverzicht und unverletzlicher
Grenzen er ist im Grunde einen Angriff
auf alles
wofür auch wir Deutsche stehen meine
Damen und Herren
wer also
schulterzuckend fragt was geht denn
dieser Krieg und sie in Deutschland an
der redet wie ich finde unverantwortlich
aber vor allem geschichtsvergessen mit
dieser Haltung können wir als Deutsche
in Europa nicht bestehen diese Haltung
ist falsch
und deshalb lieber Herr Botschafter
unterstützen wir die Ukraine solange es
nötig sein wird wir unterstützen sie
militärisch ihr Präsident hat mir gerade
berichtet wie lebensrettend die
Deutschen luftverteidigungssysteme sind
und wir unterstützen Sie auch finanziell
und politisch wir unterstützen Sie ganz
akut beim schnellen Wiederaufbau nach
Russlands wirklich niederträchtigen
Angriffen auf Strom Heizung warmes
Wasser auf alle lebenswichtigen
Infrastrukturen vor dem nahen Winter
und ich rede nicht nur Herr Botschafter
über die Unterstützung durch Politik
es gibt
so viele Menschen in Deutschland die
mithelfen die Flüchtlinge aufgenommen
haben oder Ihnen auf dem Weg in unsere
Schulen Ämter und Betriebe diesen
Menschen zur Seite stehen es gibt
unzählige zivilgesellschaftliche
Initiativen
Städtepartnerschaften kommunale
Netzwerke die ganz konkret in der
Ukraine hilfeleisten dafür möchte ich
Ihnen allen in unserem Land heute danken
Ihnen allen die diese lebenswichtige
Hilfe leisten und dafür sorgen dass sie
weitergeht meinen aufrichtigen Dank
meine Damen und Herren für das was sie
tun
aus der Rede schon
das
und weil dieser Krieg auch uns betrifft
führt auch an wirtschaftlichem Druck auf
Russland keinen Weg vorbei das sage ich
denen die mich fragen warum wir denn
Lasten tragen sollen für den Krieg in
einem anderen Land
Schaden die Sanktionen nicht viel mehr
uns selbst
können wir sie nicht einfach sein lassen
solche Fragen höre ich häufig in diesen
Tagen und ich will sie gar nicht abtun
denn diese Ängste die dahinter stehen
sind real was ich sagen will wir müssen
diese Fragen beantworten Sanktionen
Abbruch von Kontakten Waffenlieferungen
in einen tobenden Krieg
nichts davon ist Alltag nichts davon
verträgt sich mit unseren bisherigen
Vorstellungen von einem friedlichen
Miteinander
wir leben eben nicht in einer idealen
Welt wir leben im Konflikt
und dafür brauchen wir
konfliktinstrumente
und ja Sanktionen haben Kosten auch für
unsere was wäre denn die Alternative
tatenlos diesen verbrecherischen Angriff
zuschauen
einfach weitermachen als wäre nichts
geschehen
es ist doch unser Interesse dass wir uns
mit unseren Partnern
Russlands Rechtsbruch in Gegenstimmen es
ist unser Interesse dass wir uns aus
Abhängigkeiten von einem Regime lösen
das panzerrollen lässt gegen einen
Nachbarland und Energie als Waffe
benutzt es ist unser Interesse und
selbst zu schützen und unsere
Verwundbarkeit zu reduzieren niemand hat
das klarer und kürzer gesagt als die
estnische Ministerpräsidentin vor kurzem
Energiemarkt teurer werden aber die
Freiheit ist unbezahlbar
meine Damen und Herren ich habe gesagt
wir leben im Konflikt und dieser Krieg
geht uns etwas an aber ebenso wichtig
ist mir
unser Land ist nicht im Krieg
wir wollen auch nicht dass sich das Ende
deiner Ausweitung des Krieges gar eine
nukleare Eskalation die muss verhindert
werden
und ich weiß viele Menschen in unserem
Land
sehnen sich nach Frieden einige glauben
es Fehler an ernsthaften Bemühungen
unsererseits ja gar
an Bereitschaft zum Verhandeln
ich kann Ihnen versichern niemandem
niemandem der bei Sinnen ist fehlt der
Wille
aber die Wahrheit ist im Angesicht des
Bösen reicht eben gute Wille nicht aus
denn nichts anderes sind Russlands
brutale Attacken in den letzten acht
Monaten niederträchtig und
menschenverachten ein vermeintlicher
Friede der solches Handeln belohnt ein
Friede der putinslandraub besiegelt
ist kein Friede er würde für viele
Menschen in der Ukraine eine
Schreckensherrschaft bedeuten würde sie
der Wilke und Gewalt der russischen
Besatzer überlassen schlimmer noch
ein solcher scheinfriede würde
putinshunger noch vergrößern Moldawien
Georgien auch unsere Partner im Baltikum
Leben in Angst
auch die Menschen meine Damen und Herren
in die Ukraine die Frauen Männer und
Kinder die täglich vor den russischen
ankraketenangriffen in die Keller
flüchten
auch die wünschen sich Frieden
dringlicher noch als wir aber sie haben
doch recht wenn sie sagen der Friede den
wir uns ersehnen muss ein gerechter
Friede sein ein Friede der die
Unabhängigkeit die Freiheit der Ukraine
bewahrt ein schneller ungerechter
Frieden ist keine Lösung weil er den
Keim neuer Gewalt in sich trägt mehr
noch ein ungerechter Friede würde all
jene auf der Welt bestärken deren
Machthunger kein Recht
und keine Regeln kennt das kann nicht in
unserem Interesse sein
meine Damen und Herren den Frieden
wollen
[Musik]
aber Waffen ins Kampfgebiet liefern eine
Kriegspartei unterstützen aber selbst
nicht im Krieg sein Sanktionen gegen
andere beschließen aber auch selbst
darunter leiden
ja das sind Widersprüche und ich höre
jeden Tag wie viele Deutsche daran
zweifeln
manche sogar verzweifeln
was ist für uns Deutsche eine
Zerreißprobe der Gegenwind bläst tief
hinein in unser Land die neue Zeit
fordert uns heraus wie lange nicht mehr
es ist eine Zerreißprobe
die uns auch keine abnimmt und für die
es keinen einfachen Ausweg gibt
wie können wir das bestehen wie können
wir das bestehen als Land das selbst
verunsichert ist woher nehmen wir die
Stärke
Widersprüche auszuhalten wenn wir selbst
von Zweifeln geplagt sind ich glaube
dieser
Moment der Krise der muss für uns
zunächst ein Moment der
Selbstvergewisserung sein machen wir uns
klar das was uns im Kern ausmacht das
hat Bestand auch in Zeiten des
Gegenwinds bleiben wir wer wir sind eine
starke Demokratie in der Mitte Europas
seine freie vielfältige Republik von
selbstbestimmten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
will sagen was der Epochenbruch von dem
ich spreche was der verändert sind nicht
die Werte für die wir stehen
aber die Ziele müssen wir schärfen und
Anpassen auf die neuen Herausforderungen
wir wollen in zwei Jahren sagen können
wir haben die
wirtschaftliche Talsohle durchschritten
wir wollen in fünf Jahren sagen können
nicht nur die Ukraine hat ihre
Souveränität behauptet auch wir selbst
müssen keine Angst von neuen Kriegen in
Europa haben wir wollen in zehn Jahren
sagen können wir haben diese
Gesellschaft zusammengehalten mit den
schwächeren untergehakt mitgenommen und
die Mehrheit hat ihr Vertrauen in die
Demokratie bewahrt wir wollen den 15
Jahren sagen können trotz Krieg und
Krise wir haben sichergestellt dass auch
den nachfolgenden Generationen ein gutes
Leben auf unsere Erde möglich ist ja
wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich können wir die
Erfolgsgeschichte unseres Landes nicht
in derselben Taktzahl vorschreiben wie
in den letzten drei Jahrzehnten
aber das Wesentliche wird wieder wichtig
und das verdient unsere ganze Kraft und
ich sage unsere Kraft und ich sage das
sehr bewusst Liebe Landsleute diese neue
Zeit sie fordert jeden einzelnen
vielleicht könnte man in den Zeiten mit
Rückenwind noch durchkommen
ohne sich selbst großartig einzusetzen
vielleicht könnte man sich es erlauben
Politik einfach anderen zu überlassen
das gilt heute nicht mehr Deutschland
unser Land braucht ihren Willen zur
Veränderung braucht ihren Einsatz für
das Gemeinwesen damit wir dort ankommen
wo wir hinwollen was also verlangt das
Wesentliche und
was sind wir bereit uns abzufüllen klar
ist
wir müssen in den nächsten Jahren
Einschränkungen hinnehmen das spüren die
meisten längst jeder muss beitragen wo
er kann und diese Krise verlangt dass
wir wieder lernen uns zu bescheiden das
mag nun wie hohen klingen in den Ohren
derer die schon heute nicht über die
Runden kommen und ich weiß dass auch in
unserem reichen Land
viele nicht verzichten können weil ihr
gesamter Alltag bereits aus Verzicht
besteht
diese Krise trifft Menschen die schon
vor dem Kriegsausbruch jeden Tag für ihr
Auskommen zu kämpfen hatten für ihre
Wohnung oder für gutes Leben ihre Kinder
diese Krise trifft Betriebe
selbstständige Läden die gut liefen
aber jetzt wegen unterbrochener
Lieferketten hoher in den Preise in die
Schieflage geraten deshalb
muss am Beginn jeder Debatte die
Versicherung stehen unser Staat lässt
sie auch in dieser Zeit nicht allein
ersetzt seine Kraft ein um denen zu
helfen
die es allein nicht schaffen
entlastungspakete abwehrschirmen
gaspreisbremse Wohngeld und
Unterstützungsleistungen für Unternehmen
die großen wie die kleinen zeugen von
diesem Willen wichtig ist
diese Unterstützung muss jetzt rasch bei
den Betroffenen ankommen
kein Staat auch das gehört zur Wahrheit
kein Staat in Europa kann so viel für
seine Bürger tun wir unser Land
aber auch unser Staat wird nicht jede
Belastung auffangen können und er muss
es nicht denn die Krise trifft auch die
vielen denen es zum Glück gut geht die
stark sind die in den Jahren des
rückenwinds auch zu Wohlstand und
Sicherheit gekommen sind sie können sich
einschränken ohne das existenzielle Not
entsteht und es gibt auch Bereitschaft
dazu wie mir manche sogar schreiben
vertrauen wir auf diese starke Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft und schließlich
trifft diese Krise auch auf viele
wohlhabende reiche Menschen in unserem
Land Menschen die viel haben und mehr
tragen können sie müssen jetzt helfen um
die immensen Kosten der notwendigen
Entlastungen überhaupt stemmen zu können
sie müssen jetzt beitragen um neue
Ungerechtigkeiten zu vermeiden
beeindruckende entlastungspakete sind
wichtig
aber nicht weniger wichtig ist
Gerechtigkeit bei der Verteilung der
Lasten davon wird viel abhängig
Liebe Landsleute mir ist völlig klar
[Musik]
niemand schränkt sich gerne ein aber ich
wünsche mir dass wir
[Musik]
unsere Perspektive verändern dass wir
nicht als erstes fragen wer kann mir die
Last abnehmen sondern eher hilft das um
gemeinsam durch die Krise zu kommen das
ist die Haltung mit der wir jetzt so
hoffe ich gemeinsam durch den Winter
gehen
doch zur Wahrheit gehört auch
mit diesem Winter ist es nicht getan so
sehr uns die Sorgen vor Inflationen
Energiepreisen und den Krieg gerade
umtreiben
es wird auch nach diesem Winter auch
nach dieser wirtschaftlichen Talsohle
kein einfaches zurück zum davor geben
können
denn auch wenn der Krieg die politische
Tagesordnung verschoben hat
auch der Klimawandel fordert unser
entschiedenes Handeln auch und gerade
jetzt ich mache mir ehrlich gesagt
sorgen dass diese menschheitsaufgabe
zu sehr in den Hintergrund gerät der
Klimawandel macht keine Ukraine Pause
klar ist wenn wir Emissionen drastisch
reduzieren und uns von fossilen Energien
lösen wollen müssen wir manche lieb
gewordene Gewohnheit aufgeben im Kleinen
wie im Großen von der Frage wie und wie
schnell wir uns fortbewegen was wir
essen bis hin zu der Frage wie wir bauen
und wohnen auch hier kann jeder Einzelne
seinen Beitrag leisten
beginnen wir sofort damit jeder noch so
kleine Schritt ist besser als keiner
aber
trotzdem werden diese individuellen
Anstrengungen natürlich nicht ausreichen
unser Land unser
erfolgreiches Wirtschaftsmodell steht
vor einem historischen Umbau wir
verlassen gerade die
Ära der fossilen Industrialisierung eine
Ära die Deutschlands Aufstieg als
Exportnation
begründet und begleitet hat und wir
treten ein in ein Zeitalter zunehmend
ohne Kohle Öle und Gas in dem sich
Deutschland neu beweisen muss und neu
beweisen wird darin liegen bei aller
Herausforderungen über die ich spreche
auch wirklich große Chancen für unser
Land und dass wir diese Chancen
tatsächlich nutzen das neue Wohlstand
auf neuen bessere Grundlagen möglich
wird
das ist jetzt die vordringliche Aufgabe
von Ingenieurinnen und Entwicklern von
Wirtschaft und Politik und dafür dass
diese Aufgabe gelingt dafür sind unsere
Chancen wie ich finde gut
und weil der Klimawandel in der Welt nur
gemeinsam abgewendet werden kann
müssen wir auch dafür Sorge tragen dass
es in Zukunft weiterhin
Institutionen und Kooperationen geben
wird die über die wachsenden
geopolitischen Gräben hinweg eine neue
Blockkonfrontation
vermeiden eine Zweiteilung der Welt
eine Zweiteilung in wir gegen die
die ist so bin ich überzeugt nicht in
unserem Interesse ja wir müssen unsere
Verwundbarkeit reduzieren wir müssen
einseitige Abhängigkeiten verringern
aber das bedeutet eben nicht
weniger Vernetzung mit der Welt
sondern das wird Sie überraschen mehr
nicht binden an wenige sondern Chancen
und Risiken streuen deshalb rate ich uns
verlernen wir nach dem Epochenbruch über
den wir sprechen nicht all das was
deutsche Außenpolitik stark gemacht hat
die europäische Verankerung das Bemühen
um internationale Zusammenarbeit um
gemeinsame Regeln der Dialog zwischen
den verschiedenen das Werben um Partner
die anders sind als wir das ist eben
keine Stilfrage
Überlebensfrage
ohne den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel ist
alles nichts er braucht unsere ganze
Kraft beweisen wir jetzt unsere Stärke
in der Veränderung ermöglichen wir
unseren Kindern und Kindeskindern ein
gutes Leben auf unserem Planeten wir
haben das in der Hand
meine Damen und Herren wir schränken uns
ein um durch die Krise zu kommen wir
verändern uns um unsere Erde zu erhalten
noch ein drittes wird uns abverlangt in
dieser Epoche wir brauchen
aktive
widerstandskräftige Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
denn in diesen Zeiten des Gegenwinds
nehmen die Angriffe auf unsere freie
Gesellschaft zu Putin versucht Europa zu
spalten und der trägt dieses Gift
auch ins Innere unserer Gesellschaft wir
sind verletzlich weil wir offen sind und
weil wir auch offen bleiben wollen das
Netz der Bahn des freie Internet die
Software auf unseren Handys unsere
Energieversorgung
all das das wissen sie ist bereits Ziel
von Angriffen geworden wir werden uns
besser schützen müssen aber
ab meine Damen und Herren auch unsere
Demokratie gehört zur kritischen
Infrastruktur und sie steht unter Druck
sie schützen können nur wir selbst
das verlangt von uns Demokraten mehr als
Bekenntnis er ist verlangt Engagement
und auch hier wieder Widerstandsgeist
Widerstandskraft
widerstandskräftige Bürger treten ein
für ihre Meinungen äußern ihre Sorgen
aber sie lassen sich nicht vereinnahmen
von denen die unsere Demokratie
attackieren
widerstandskräftige Bürger unterscheiden
zwischen notwendigen Kritikern
politischen Entscheidungen
und dem Generalangriff auf unser
politisches System
widerstandskräftige Bürger halten
Unsicherheit aus
und lassen sich nicht verführen von
denen die einfache Lösungen versprechen
sie erwarten mit Recht das Politik sich
in dieser schwierigen Zeit auf das
wichtigste konzentriert das Pragmatismus
über ritualisierte Schaukämpfe sägt
widerstandskräftige Bürger fordern
Freiraum für Ihre eigene Art zu leben
aber vergessen nicht wie sehr wir alle
auf andere angewiesen sind
widerstandskräftige Bürger Verlangen
sich etwas ab Respekt und Vernunft zum
Beispiel
das ist schwer richtig schwer
aber nur so können wir dem Gift des
Populismus der Gefahr des
auseinanderdriftens wirksam etwas
entgegensetzen
und am Ende kommt es auch darauf an wenn
wir im Gegenwind stehen anstatt uns
weiter auseinandertreiben zu lassen
müssen wir alles Stärken was uns
verbindet
alle Stärken was uns verbindet zum
Beispiel zwischen Jung und Alt viele
jüngere Menschen sind ungeduldig
werfen den älteren vor dass sie zu
sorglos mit unserem Planeten umgegangen
sind zu zögerlich umgesteuert haben die
Jüngeren fühlen sich betrogen die
älteren fühlen sich abgewertet in dem
was sie für ihre Kinder und ihr Land
getan haben
spielen wir meine Damen und Herren nicht
die Generationen gegeneinander aus
daraus kann nichts Gemeinsames entstehen
und wir alle haben doch hoffentlich das
gleiche Ziel wir wollen unser Land
verändern wir wollen es zu einem
besseren machen und das geht eben nur
gemeinsam und so kommt es
auf uns Ältere auf meine Generation
kommt jetzt die Aufgabe zu selbst später
im Leben das gewohnte nochmals
überdenken
mitzuhelfen das Veränderung gelingt und
den jüngeren auch den vielen hier im
Saal sage ich jetzt an euch in die
Verantwortung zu gehen euch einzubringen
gerne kritisch nicht destruktiv und
unser Land zu verändern sei es
vielleicht vielleicht sogar besser zu
machen
als die Generation davor meine
Unterstützung habt ihr haben sie
oder schauen wir auf manches
Unverständnis zwischen Ost und West
auch hier ist zu stärken was uns
verbindet viele Menschen in
Ostdeutschland erleben gerade gefühlt
gefühlt die Rückkehr in die 90er Jahre
als schon einmal Sicherheiten
einstürzten und Existenzen
zusammenbrachen wie viel von dieser
Erfahrung von dieser Angst ist im Westen
wirklich angekommen wir müssen es
diesmal besser machen im Angesicht einer
Krise die den Osten erneut härter trifft
weil natürlich auch 32 Jahre nach der
Wiedervereinigung die Energieversorgung
schwieriger die Einkommen niedriger und
die Ersparnisse geringer sind bei dem
Menschen zu stärken was uns verbindet
bedeutet heute dafür zu sorgen dass der
Osten nicht hinten runterfällt und ich
weiß dass dort
die Sorgen groß sind aber ich weiß auch
wie viel Licht am Horizont des wie viele
Gründer wie viel innovative Technologien
auf Weltniveau aus Ostdeutschland kommen
dankbester Universitäten und
Forschungsinstitute ein Unternehmen aus
Thüringen ist gerade zum zweiten Mal mit
dem Deutschen Zukunftspreis
ausgezeichnet worden er sehnte
Ansiedlungen von halbleiterproduktionen
finden in Sachsen und demnächst auch in
Sachsen-Anhalt statt führende
Unternehmen der Elektromobilität finden
auch in Brandenburg ihren Platz das
alles sind mehr als ermutigende
Einzelfälle arbeiten wir an dieser neuen
und nachhaltigen Stärke Ostdeutschlands
das ist unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe
und das Verbindende zu stärken diese
Aufgabe stellt sich auch zwischen Stadt
und Land viele Menschen die in
ländlichen Regionen leben
[Musik]
und das ist die Mehrheit in unserem Land
finden sich nicht wieder in den Debatten
die wir in der Hauptstadt führen
Debatten die häufig noch viel weiter von
ihren tatsächlichen Problemen entfernt
sind als der nächste Facharzt oder die
Poststelle
umgekehrt blicken viele Menschen in der
Großstadt manchmal
in einer
Mischung aus Verklärung und
Überheblichkeit auf die ländlichen Räume
sehnen sich nach Ruh und
Abgeschiedenheit die man aber nur im
Wochenende genießen will
wann es häufig fehlt ist die ehrliche
Anerkennung von unterschiedlichen
Lebensbedingungen von Stadt und Land
woran es fehlte ist die Bereitschaft die
Bedürfnisse von Menschen im ländlichen
Raum ernst zu nehmen auch die
Lebensqualität in den Dörfern und
kleinen Städten zu erhalten und dazu
braucht es mehr als nur eine stabile
Internetverbindung es verlangt
Aufmerksamkeit
und es verlangt Respekt für ein anderes
Leben wagen wir doch ruhig häuft da
immer häufiger mal den Blick über den
eigenen Tellerrand über die eigene
Wirklichkeit hinweg ich glaube das
können das müssen wir uns abverlangen in
unserem gemeinsamen Land
meine Damen und Herren Reich und Arm
Jung und Alt Stadt und Land Verbindungen
Stärken über Generationen vor allen
Dingen überlebenswelten hinweg
darum geht es mir und ich bin jedem
dankbar ich bin jedem dankbar der an mir
denkt als nur sich selbst
viele Menschen in unserem Land tun es
und diese Menschen sind das Rückgrat
unserer Gesellschaft aber
dieses Lob aufs Ehrenamt
das darf nicht mehr nur Sache von
sonntags reden sein fakt ist das
klassische Ehrenamt das klassische
Ehrenamt altert
Verantwortung verteilt sich auf wenige
Schultern dabei ist der Einsatz für
andere gerade in den Zeiten des
Gegenwinds von denen ich rede
unverzichtbar oder ich könnte sagen
systemrelevant eben deshalb müssen wir
neue Wege finden wie wir
Entfremdung entgegenwirken unsere
Gesellschaft unseren Gemeinden Stärken
dazu habe ich einen Vorschlag gemacht
und ich sage es offen ich habe auch
nicht erwartet dass die Idee der
sozialen Pflicht Zeit nur Begeisterung
hervorruft was ich will ist eine
ehrliche Debatte über unsere Engagement
für das gemeinsame ganze eine Debatte
die hoffentlich nicht wieder im Nichts
enden wird ich bin jedenfalls ich bin
und bleibe überzeugt dass es keine
Zumutung ist wenn wir die Menschen
fragen was sie für den Zusammenhalt in
diesem Lande zu tun bereit sind denn und
das ist meine wirklich tiefe Überzeugung
Demokratie geht nicht ohne Zusammenhalt
und Zusammenhalt entsteht nicht einfach
nur von selbst der muss auch eingeübt
werden es ist Ergebnis von Menschen von
Empathie
von Verantwortung
von Nächstenliebe
die Idee der sozialen Pflicht seit
einfach nur abzulehnen
[Musik]
das ist keine Antwort auf der
Herausforderung unserer Zeit vielleicht
gibt es andere überzeugende Konzepte
aber soll das ewige plädo-g für
Zusammenhalt nicht folgenlos bleiben
dann brauchen wir mehr
Ideen und mehr Menschen die mindestens
einmal im Leben für eine gewisse Zeit
sich den sorgen ganz anderer zuvor
fremder Menschen widmen für diese
Menschen schlicht und einfach da sind so
meine Damen und Herren liebe Gäste zum
Schluss
Staatsbürger und StaatsbürgerInnen zu
sein
in Zeiten der Krise
Widerstandskraft beweisen im Gegenwind
das verlangt uns etwas ab wir stehen
heute zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte
des vereinten Deutschlands gemeinsam an
einem Scheitelpunkt trauen wir uns zu
aufzubrechen in diese neue Zeit mit
ihren neuen Herausforderungen sind wir
gewappnet für das
was uns von uns gefordert wird
ich bin überzeugt aus dieser
Herausforderung heraus kann neue Stärke
kann auch neue Einheit wachsen es wird
nicht einfach sein und es wird
anstrengend sein ja
wir werden eine Zeit der Belastung und
der Unsicherheiten durchlaufen bevor wir
neue Sicherheiten und wieder ganz festen
Grund unter unseren Füßen haben ich
wünsche mir
dass wir uns bei all den Mühen nicht aus
den Augen verlieren dass wir unsere
Kraft jetzt nicht im täglichen
gegeneinander vergeuden wenn wir
zusammenhalten
wenn wir Mut und Ehrgeiz beweisen dann
ich bin nicht mehr sicher wir werden
diese Aufgabe gewachsen sein wir
bewahren unsere Freiheit unsere
Demokratie wir machen Deutschland zu
einer neuen Industrienation
technologisch führend
klimaverantwortlich in der Mitte Europas
vernetzt aber weniger verwundbar
wehrhaft aber nicht kriegerisch
ein offenes freundliches Land mit mehr
und neuen internationalen Partnern ich
bin überzeugt unser Land hat die Kraft
Krisen zu überwinden es hat die Menschen
die immer wieder dafür arbeiten die
Unternehmerinnen die forscheringenieure
FacharbeiterInnen unser Land hat das
Wissen und die Ideen die Erfahrung von
Generationen
und den Ehrgeiz der Jugend
vertrauen wir einander
und vertrauen wir uns selbst und lassen
wir uns nicht den mutigen vom Gegenwind
der uns in dieser neuen Zeit entgegen
wird es kommt nicht darauf an dass alle
dasselbe tun aber dass wir eines
gemeinsam in Sinn haben
alles zu stärken was uns verbindet das
ist die Aufgabe tun wir es vielen Dank
das war sie also die Rede des
Bundespräsidenten an alle Deutschen die
ja auch als seine Landsleute bezeichnet
eine Rede eine ja auch selbstkritische
Rede zur Lage der Nation bei uns im
Studio Peter Thiede unser Bild Chef
Reporter mit einer kurzen blitzanalyse
das wollen wir alles analysieren was und
wir es gesagt hat wie wirkte diese Rede
auf dich die war ehrlich aber es waren
natürlich wieder wie so viele reden die
Frankfurter Steinmeier hält das waren
wirklich große Rede die war gut
geschrieben aber es ist halt der
Bundespräsident der einmal immer in
jeder Rede seine eigene Ära beenden muss
auch hier dass sie beendet er war der
Architekt unser fehlgeleiteten Russland
Politik die uns in die Krise reingeführt
hat aus die er jetzt mit seiner Rede
einen Weg weist als Bundespräsident der
nicht zu entscheiden hat aber der quasi
zum Volk sprechen kann die geht aber gut
die Rede war lang die Rede hat wirklich
viele Aspekte abgedeckt aber lass uns
mal rein und es gab wirklich
bemerkenswerte stellen ja wir schauen
auf ein paar Sätze von ihnen noch mal
vom Bundespräsidenten aus dieser Rede an
alle deutschen und dazu zählen diese
zentralen er spricht über das Scheitern
in den vergangenen Jahren das Scheitern
und nennt dann auch sein eigenes
Scheitern schauen wir uns diesen Satz
noch mal an also er geht zunächst in
diese ersten Kriegstage in dass sie
reden Geheule über Kiew morgens sie
gingen mir unter die Haut sagt er in
diesem Moment eine kommt ja gerade in
dieser Woche aus Kiew zurück der
Frank-Walter Steinmeier und dann sagt er
sie markieren das endgültige bittere
scheitern jahrelanger politischer
Bemühungen auch meiner Bemühung das
Scheitern von Frank-Walter
steinmeier-peter na das Scheitern von
Frank-Walter Steinmeier das mit
wesentlich auch dazu beigetragen hat das
Wladimir Putin zum zweiten Mal die
Ukraine würde ich massiv an greifen
konnte nach 2014 er war der Architekt
der gescheiterten russland-politik er
war der Architekt der gescheiterten
Ukraine Politik und dass die Ukraine
heute dermaßen tief in diesem
kriegslermasse sitzt hat er mit nicht
hauptsächlich zu Verantwortung damit zu
verantworten und da muss er dann in so
einer Rede auch erst sagt man selber
wieder zu sich selber kommen und wir
wohnen bei diesem Bundespräsidenten an
der permanenten Selbstfindung bei dazu
zählt auch dieser Satz Peter er sagt es
kommen härtere Jahre raue Jahre auf uns
zu Friedensdividende die sei aufgezerrt
jetzt beginne für Deutschland eine
Epoche im Gegenwind er schwört uns ein
auf eine harte Zeit und bietet uns seine
Idee wieder an führen Zusammenhalt er
wirbt ihr für das soziale pflichtlehr
für das Deutschland ja und macht Druck
jetzt auf die aktuelle Politik wenn ihr
keine besseren Vorschläge habt dann
setzt das Ding doch jetzt um er sagt das
darf nicht wieder im Nichts enden die
diese Debatte und auch hier dieses
schwierigen Jahre der Gegenwind dem hat
er vorher die die Jahre des Rückenwindes
entgegengesetzt die er fest macht ab der
deutschen Einheit hatten wir quasi
Friedens die Dividende auch da schwingt
aber das ist das Problem dieses
Bundespräsidenten ist schwebt immer es
schwingt immer sein eigenes scheiter mit
dabei und deswegen tut man sich
tatsächlich schwer er war in den Zeiten
des Rückenwindes derjenige der mit am
Steuer stand und nicht in die richtige
Richtung gefüttert mir geht's immer so
ganz viel von dem was er da sagt stimmt
und er hatte auch recht mit wir brauchen
einen soziales Lichtjahr aber ist er
derjenige dem ich jetzt am Steuern doch
vertrauen kann ist es der das schwingt
bald bei mir mit es war eine große Rede
aber er fordert Sachen ein wo man sagt
du warst so lange wirklich in eigener
Verantwortung
hättest Du vieles damals schon richtig
machen können warum sollen jetzt andere
auf dich hören das ist mein Problem mit
ihm abschließend ja nein hat er sich die
Herzen der deutschen mit dieser Rede
zurückerobert der hat in einigen Punkten
wirklich gute Punkte gemacht und was mir
besonders nahe ging war als wir über
Stadt und Land gesprochen hat die
arrogante Sichtweise und wie wir
vergessen was auf den Dörfern los ist
und wie in der Berliner Blase darüber
geredet wird das ist etwas da hatte ein
Zusammenhalt wirklich dann zum zum zum
Ende hin rangepackt aber wie gesagt wir
wohnen einer permanenten selbständung
das Frankfurter Steinmeier bei mein
Fazit nach dieser Rede er ist jetzt da
wo die Masse der Deutschen schon lange
war führen tut er das noch nicht danke
für deine blitzanalyse zur Rede an alle
deutschen vom Bundespräsidenten
Frank-Walter Steinmeier bei uns dazu
Chefreporter Peter Tide danke dir
[Musik]